with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense upbeat and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may act eight each
other and you thought-provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge there was sad news
this week as it was revealed that the
friendship tree given to Donald Trump by
French president Emmanuel macron had
died after being removed from the White
House grounds and placed in quarantine
but the idea of giving a gift as a mark
of companionship inspired me to get a
present for one of my fellow panelist
Greg I present you with our friendship
it looks innocent enough until you
encounter its relationship it's actually
fallen over okay coming up Nicktoons
into the debate over free TV licenses
June argues everyone is equal no matter
how much you pay in rent rachel kicks
off about the Women's World Cup and I'm
saying big isn't better but first it's
quick there's been an enormous amount of
fuss this week following Michael Gove
submission that he took cocaine as a
young journalist some of his competitors
for the role of Tory leader and prime
minister I've tried to exploit his
discomfort hoping to bump him out of the
race while the front-runner you know the
one with all the blond hair
he hasn't even mentioned it but then
given that in the past he admitted
taking drugs being an adulterer and his
known as a notorious womanizer that's
not surprising but does any of this
really matter now current prime minister
said the most outrageous thing she'd
ever done was to run for a fully grown
wheat field she wasn't even naked and
look at the mess she got us into we
should judge potential leaders by their
track record in work and politics by
their leadership qualities there are
ideas for the future and of course their
plan to get us out of the brexit mess we
shouldn't judge them
but what they did in an earlier life
when they were carefully and
irresponsible surely that's what being
young is all about Ruth everything you
just said you know past mistakes should
not determine someone's future so what
they do now what they're gonna do in the
future the cans and and the fact of the
matter is the generation from which this
Prime Minister will be chosen and ones
in the future will have come into
contact with a lot of drugs I think I
mean this this is never about drug use
per se was it this is about politics
it's about spite it's about payback it's
about people who don't want him to get
the big job but it's it's the stench of
hypocrisy around all this it's got me
you know you've got senior policemen
saying that middle-class users have
blood on my hands because it fuels the
drug gang same cops who've ignored
cocaine use for the past 20 years so I
just I didn't do you guys remember it
I'm sure you remember the story of the
son in 2013 when they went in to the
House of Commons yes and to the toilets
ninth is that all the MPs use there was
cocaine traces in every one of those
toilets so Michael Gove used to 20 years
ago some people are still got say every
MP there was 9th eyelets that they went
into these offices and there were traces
of cocaine found in all of those times
so you know so this Michael Gove hasn't
used it for many years but the question
that I want to ask all you guys and you
kind of touched on it is that what is
worse is past drug abuse worse or is
infidelity what's because what people
have been saying is what is criminal and
what isn't and that is the reality this
that what it's done for Michael Gove is
class-a hypocrisy not Class A drugs
because you cannot be writing articles
questioning it all when in fact you
I don't care by the way if Michael as
long as he's not doing it now if he is
the man and I don't care about Boris
Johnson's past if he is the man I don't
care about and real Edson's past if she
is the woman but you cannot do one thing
and preach against it that is what we'll
do for microwave and just lastly and
just lastly I think it is fantastic that
we are having the conservative hustings
that we're having now because if it had
happened last time
remember Theresa May went in apps
unopposed the only one going other was
Andrea led some who had an unfortunate
article with the times in which she
talks about being a parent having a
gator investment so she stood out I
firmly believe that had to resume been
having the baptism of fire that all 10
of them
which will become nine who have become I
think Andrea Letson will probably have
fared better and we might I say we might
we might not be in a situation in which
we find ourselves
I think but I agree with both of you
that the stench of hypocrisy is in the
air on this and we must actually add
that Michael Gove was not a young
journalist he was thirty years old I've
had three kids by the time I was thirty
he was also writing opinion columns in
the times in which he invade against
Channel Four's cocaine night special so
yes he's a hypocrite but I also think
what might do for him in terms of the
leadership is there's a sense that you
know there's a joke about coke that it's
God's Way of telling you've got too much
money and the optic around you know the
MPs doing coke is again were being ruled
by a sort of posh white boy
cleek who have got enough money I'm not
talking about here but he's a posh white
boy he's he's not that posh but he is a
white boy hold on wait wait wait wait
which is bad that because it's like this
is what everyone but not this is very
actual what you can't not one before you
take me off on blow me off course on to
the Boris conversation which is that
this the sense that there is a
disconnect between the country where
probably they can't afford coke because
they can do horse ketamine in bus
shelters and lung and in Westminster
whether doing coke even in the
parliamentary estate that is the bad
news for Michael Gove just add to what
you've all said for me like you Nick I
don't particularly care whether or not
he took coke as a young man or a man in
his 30s though I do think what is
significant with him is because he was
in charge of the Department of Justice
for a very long time and actually this
is something years later yes 15 years
later and would have been prosecuting
people
were doing exactly the same thing and he
did so that's where the hypocrisy is and
I and there's a great quote video that
we have from Chief Constable Tim look
Tom Lloyd who makes this very point
let's have a look
we shouldn't be prosecuting people for
drug possession and drug use we should
be changing the system completely but we
haven't done that and the reason we
haven't done it is that it's politicians
like Mr Gove but in fact almost all of
them who are insisting that they can be
forgiven and move on and yet at the same
time they're supporting the prosecution
of people who are doing exactly what
they've done now that's just hypocrisy
in my view so for me that's my problem
with it can I ask you a question Greg
you know when you were boss at the BBC
if someone had if it came to your
attention that someone that had a
powerful job had taken cocaine years ago
one factors take you know what would you
do
in both cases years ago and now years
ago I mean I think if you go around I
mean there's some figures I mean I think
9 percent of 16 to 59 year olds in the
last year so they took drugs yeah well
if you'd ask them the question have you
ever taken drugs I suspect you're up to
60 70 80 percent I'm reputed most people
in their youth has taken drugs or
something so in terms of history now in
terms of are you doing it now is it
affecting their performance it's as
simple as that so you wouldn't even do
what if you're taking it now well if it
was effective against ment of the
presenters or backwards but is it facing
robbery it's illegal it's illegal
currently it's legal not who actually
had the power to do something about it
in terms of it being illegal and I think
if he knows he's did he had dabbled in
it then surely this is something that
I've talked to lots of MPs who believe
that the counter laws and the cameras on
drugs are ridiculous but the real
problem is they're never gonna do
anything about it because they mean this
game
of the attack in the media in the sign
of the mile or something like that isn't
the point of my go you know we complain
about our politics our current
politicians and and and and what they
are what they do isn't the Booker was a
very clever man and and I want clever
men in cabinet I want clever men zero
setting the rules for us
I want Trevor men and women setting the
rules and and the fact that he did
something 20 years ago shouldn't do by
him from taking my free I I totally
agree with you Carol all I'm saying is
that when he was in the Department of
Justice he was dealing with this very
issue perhaps the time to admit it would
have been then and to say that you know
what I have a different perspective
I don't know whether you saw him being
interviewed on the weekend
well you certainly would've seen clips
on your time you see how do you think he
dealt with it
I thought he dealt with it extremely
well because he acknowledged that what
he did was wrong he said he was sorry he
also acknowledged that it's not a
victimless crime that he did in his
youth okay there is such a long tail
it's it's the dealers it's the people
who are the Mules it's you know anyone
who's seen narcos knows that people
middle class users of cocaine as he
Michael Gove former Justice ectly right
rightly acknowledged there are you know
industrial victims of this crime and it
sort of almost comparable to child
pornography it's people who watched
child porn are actually participating in
in the industry it could be some time
before this story blows over but we move
on